طيب عمار نبدا معك صوره والاخرى واحنا
وانت تفسر طبعا لغه جسد جورجينا الحسنا
جورجينا اول واحده بنشوفها على الهواء
اوقاتكم جميعا طبعا كان الشائع كثير
بالسوشال ميديا همم شويه بطريقه شويه انه
تهكم على موضوع جورجينا وظهورها بالملعب
بس هو بصراحه يعني كان ظهورها ظهور ملكات
مع انه هي حتى لو رونالدو
هم اشخاص يعني مدربين اصلا مثل هذا
الموضوع بس جورجينا كانت اقوى من ميسي همم
عفوا اقوى من رونالدو
وبتعرف تمشي على الثلج
بهذه الامور بالعكس كان ظهورها كثير جميل
وكنت عم تعمل همم يعني نفس الانتباه بيحدث
كبير مثل هذا لاول مره هما مش معتدين اصلا
استقبال كلهم على مستوى العالم باي
فعاليات اخرى
انا عمار هي جميله جدا ام ان لغه جسدها
قويه جدا لتجذب الملايين وتصبح اسطوره مثل
كريستيانو
مشيتها القويه واعتمادها على شركتها مع
شريكها هو اللي خلاها قادره تبرز نفسها
وتستثمر هذا الشيء بطريقه صحيحه بذكاء
طبعا
رونالدو
[موسيقى]
بالثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه بشكل اوسط
وعامله دراسه كويس وكان محترمه جدا
بظهورها بهذه الطريقه رغم انه بسلوكها
وهذا المكان غريب عليهم اصلا فمع ذلك كان
ميسي يعني عفوا كان رونالدو عم يحاول انه
هو همم يشوف رضاها هل هي مرتاحه بالحقيقه
الجديده بيعرفوا طبيعتها
مرتبك اكثر منها بصراحه